about
men having
um like men never being able to get over
their first love so i feel like men
always have the one that got away but
women don't really like whenever i feel
like i've moved on from a relationship
no i mean i've only had like one serious
relationship but i feel like
i've been able to like fully heal from
that and move on
whilst i feel like
i've heard a lot of men speak about how
they're never able to move on so
maybe i feel like women's emotional
response is
greater in the moment
men's is kind of like lived out longer
if that makes sense mm-hmm i'll say as
i'm i was gonna ask you as a guy yeah
you are a man do you think that's the
thing i don't think that's the thing i
think it's more so discipline amongst
the person itself like if you do not
want to get over that first love that
you ever had that is a choice that
you've made yeah like don't get me wrong
people go oh i can't do it i can't get
over them they're the love of my life
but really and truly if that person is
out of your life you've made a choice as
to whether you want to detach from them
or you want to keep that feeling that
feeling can be very addictive
in its own right so people wanting to
keep it i totally understand but more so
is it conducive for the next
relationship do you know that it's going
to be bad for the relationship and are
you willing to make the changes
necessary in order to ensure that
doesn't happen or it doesn't affect your
next relationship
right
i agree yes i agree i think it depends
on the person and that common i think
it's because you are confident and you
know who you are there's a lot of people
they don't know who they are who they
are and they don't love they don't
self-love themselves enough so that's
why they kind of like get still they are
stuck like oh my gosh this is my first
love i don't think self-love is like a
thing
it is a thing i do self-love myself what
no i think it's like every time i hear a
girl talk about self-love respectfully
this is offensive
i don't get offended but i'm just like
what a girl talk about self-love it's
just like
her
making
excuses for poor behavior at times well
that's the thing is like you know
that's the problem with all these
buzzwords that start going crazy in
social media like self speaking
like self love and narcissism and i just
feel like there's so many buzzwords that
just get a bad rap because people just
regret
them in order to
like it's the same thing with astrology
and spirituality and all this like these
are not inherently bad things it's just
like certain people use it as a way to
you know like just justify their bad
behavior and it just like makes it look
bad for everybody but i do feel like
self-love is necessary i mean if you
don't have that then you're just gonna
make choices out of fear like
because when you
live through self-love you live through
truly like valuing yourself and making
choices that are good for you and trying
to maintain yourself
away from a fear-based mentality which
is what we were talking about earlier
which i feel like conduces to the to the
bad choices you know and i also believe
that you
if you self-love then you do not seek
validation from people yes you actually
know what you're worth you actually know
what you need and what what is yourself
at least you understand yourself better
you understand your needs so you do not
seek for someone to tell you oh you look
nice today oh um i like you or something
like you actually know your worth so you
wouldn't even lower your expectations as
you said earlier and also you will
understand where you're standing at the
moment i'm not saying self-love as if
you're the best person or just like
reach a point to arrogance but at least
you know what you act where you stand at
the moment so you can understand that
you don't need someone or you do not
seek anything from someone else if that
makes sense so this is just like my
experience with self love like girls
that's about this it's like usually just
a
okay to be delusional
and like kind of outpace where they're
actually at in life
like for example they'll say oh i did
like i love myself i like i don't
deserve i'm i'm gonna reject these guys
like i'm above them in some way they
kind of insinuate that's the thing right
but but to me it's like if those are the
guys that are approaching you and
interested in you that's that's what you
deserve because that's what you're worth
is like what you're like how could i say
like if i if i don't get offered a job
that's a hundred thousand dollars how
can i say oh i'm worth a hundred
thousand dollars but girls will be like
oh i'm 300 pounds but i'm worth a guy
that makes six figures and a six feet
tall and is all this stuff but if you
don't have those men approaching you
like how do you
how can you say you deserve them
that's the thing so self-love shouldn't
reach a certain point that you would
think that you're beyond everyone or
you're above everything it should be
limited because anything excessive is
wrong
right so you should you should know what
your expectations are and you should
know what you're worth at least what
what you expect from people do not go
beyond everything and if someone comes
and it's perfect for you you will be in
a state they'll be like nah i need
someone better do not reach that state
but reach a state where you do not need
someone that would that you know would
treat you badly but still be like oh no
because he said that okay i'm going with
him if that makes sense yeah and i feel
like if you're coming into dating from a
self-love perspective if you're doing it
from like what you just said like
feeling like oh i love myself so i
deserve a guy that's six foot and rich
it's like
well that's not really self-love that's
like being superficial right that's what
feminism has taught people
is that if you love yourself and you
think
you deserve that high value man go for
it
even if you are not in
in that same caliber or doing the things
that you need to do to be with that man
and keep that man it just has taught
taught us that self self love you can
put yourself on a pedestal and whatever
you think you deserve that's exactly
even if it's astronomical out of this
world just unrealistic it's okay you can
do it because of feminism that's what i
think well and and the other thing i was
going to add is like when you go into a
relationship it's not about you
like it's about like about who got who
who what guy wants to date a girl that's
all about me
most of the girls that spout self love
are selfish is in my experience and you
guys know but that's the thing maybe
this room is the exception i don't know
but in my experience like with those
girls like typically it's about me me me
they don't have anything to offer to a
guy other outside of hooking up they
don't cook they don't clean they don't
like do any of the things i don't cook i
don't know
but cardi b that's a perfect example of
someone who would say something like she
does i know i should she actually did a
video and offset was like filming that's
probably why she was actually cleaning
the floor at her grandma but that's the
thing a lot she's very humble a lot of
these women say they don't need men and
talk down on men in their music but like
back home what are they doing
like cardi b she like her music i don't
cook i don't clean we get she's married
she goes back to the cheaters money
she's getting higher and cleaner i don't
know she can't she's a business
that she's promoting yeah she's
promoting yeah you don't need to cook
you know another time but that i think
that line comes from like back in the
day like women they were just meant to
be doing that you know and they were
just being perceived as that as
housewives as cleaners as mothers and
shut up and you don't do anything else
and you don't say and you have no power
and that's unfair you know and that's
why i think it came from from there i
don't think it's that deep personally in
regards to those lyrics she's
in my opinion saying i don't cook i
don't clean because i don't have to like
whap
yeah but let me tell you how i got this
ring right
w.a.p what you're saying is true yeah
back in the day women did take on that
domestic role but for that context she's
basically shedding light on the fact of
you don't even need to be able to do the
things that you should want to do for
yourself forget a relationship a husband
you should be able to do that as a bare
minimum for yourself so yeah
i think it's i think it's about the
culture though yeah because you know
what that song sounds like it sounds
like i'm not doing it for a guy
like i i think we can like try to wrap
it around and that it's not but come on
like but you are very in favor uh in men
in a relationship but i think when you
are in a relationship it has to be go
both ways oh it's not just me cleaning
and cooking it's not just mutating
myself and it's not just me during the
house you know it's both both have to
help or we hire a cleaner
but here's the thing i don't know i said
that i go both ways i tell women the
bums if your guys not working get out
like leave him like don't don't stay
with a bum ass dude but i think it's
both ways like with women like i have
brothers and i i think it's important
that they have standards for women
outside of just being pretty and like
looking nice and like we should try to
earn that the men that we want to be
with